Hello,
and welcome back to the complete guide to
Teleport.
Today is a short tutorial
on how you can take a existing Teleport
cluster, which you've already seen
many times now throughout this course, how to
configure and get started.
And we're going to,
through the use of some YAML and the
GitHub application, enable single sign on that works
against
teams and organizations
on GitHub.
So most likely
where your developers already are or your operators,
etcetera.
Now,
before we get started, I will say this
was supposed to be the the first tutorial
that was going to livestream to YouTube
where we are now, but also to Twitter
and to LinkedIn
and to
somewhere else.
But I made a boo boo.
I accidentally hit start stream and end stream,
which now means I can no longer send
it to those other destinations. So we're gonna
make YouTube. So if you're watching, thank you
for joining. We're gonna get started right away.
So
we have a screen share here.
Hopefully, this is still the same machine.
It is indeed.
What we have here is an Ubuntu box
with Teleport already pre configured, web DNS enabled.
Again, these have been covered in prior videos,
so we're not going to be doing that
today.
What we do have
Where's my public IPv4
address?
I'm being really silly.
Alright.
I'll
just get it from
here. This is my public IPv4 address.
And we have a browser here where I
have the documentation on setting up single sign
on with GitHub,
the IP address, which we actually don't need
because I have this configured as Teleport.Rawkode.live.
Now I haven't created a single user on
this via
the Teleport control command. So this is a
working
Teleport instance, but there are no users. I
literally could not log into this if I
wanted to.
So we're gonna work through the process, which
is documented here for setting this up. Now
the first thing the documentation wants you to
do is is just to confirm some versions.
We definitely could run this, but I I
know that we run the latest version of
Teleport nine, so I'm not gonna run the
same commands again just now. We can run
t control status, although I actually don't have
my local machine configured with this Teleport cluster.
So I'm not going to run that, but
we could run it inside the cluster.
And we can see there.
Perfect.
Okay. So in order for this to work,
we have to be able to create a
GitHub
authentication
and what this let me make that a
little bit bigger for you. Go.
What this is telling us here is that
we need a DNS name configured because GitHub
is gonna redirect the traffic on the OAuth
dance back to our Teleport server.
I guess you could do this with just
IP addresses, but doing this is a lot
nicer.
And we need the path postfix
that we've got onto the end.
So we need to create an OAuth application.
This link goes to the documentation.
I'm going to bypass that, copy this and
just go straight to github.com
where we have the Rawkode Academy GitHub.
From here, we can go to settings.
And if we scroll down
and go to GitHub applications,
Maybe
I need my
I'm trying to do this myself rather than
as an organization.
Oh, there we go.
New OAuth application and we will call this
Teleport
Tutorial.
And then let's just say Rawkode.live.
Now the operation callback is this thing, but
we need to swap out our proxy address
for teleport.rockode.live.
So if we zoom in on that, you'll
see our authorization callback is just our domain
with the postfix.
We can register this application and we're gonna
get some secret details, which I can't remember
are visually visible.
Oh, okay. Cool. So we can copy this
client ID and then generate a new secret
when required. But we're gonna go back to
the Teleport documentation first,
and we're gonna start specking out this YAML.
So everything in Teleport can be configured through
t control
apply and a YAML link interface.
So I'll do this in the ATC directory
because we actually already have
our teleport.YAML
here. So
what I found works rather well is just
to do a teleport.GitHub.YAML,
gif, gif hub.
Yes. I am live now.
I hope.
Yeah. I'm live.
Can't make it through. I should be. So
teleport.gif.yaml.
We will drop in all this YAML and
we come up to the top. Now we
can just remove the comments. Those are far
from important just now. We can see here
we need our client ID and client secrets.
We'll come back to that.
Displays us as GitHub.
We add our redirect URL here.
This
is Teleport.Rawkode.
Yeah. I'm live. Yeah. Thanks, Russell.
I guess this this is the first tutorial
that I've done live. Normally, I just prerecorded.
I decided
to try and livestream this one today. So
if you prefer the prerecorded, just let me
know. I won't do it again.
So organization
is I'm going to allow the Rawkode Academy
organization
to
log in to the best Teleport cluster.
And then we can specify the teams
or the team.
And I'm going to say the team will
be a tutorial. So I'll create a new
team that gives me access to this when
we're ready.
And then we can decide
what access
we want to give to this. Now, of
course we could do
editor,
audit,
etcetera.
However, I'm just going to do access
for now
and remove that comment.
So this is pretty close.
So let's swap out these missing values.
So let's grab our client ID from our
newly created
GitHub authentication
app
And
we'll generate a secret,
which I'll delete ASAP.
We'll use it for today.
Copy. There's no point in trying to hide
this because I need to paste into them.
Like so.
So I think,
don't wanna get too confident, but I think
this is enough.
So we save this file.
You can cat it just so you can
see that there's nothing changed. It's exactly what
as we did. And then we can do
a t control apply
dash f GitHub.
Does it not apply? I'm not being silly.
Create.
Apply with b kip control.
Like so. And now it's telling us that
our authentication connected GitHub has been created.
What this means is that if we come
to this page and we refresh, that we
will no longer be presented with the manual
slash custom login screen
like so.
Now, of course, we can if we had
local users, but we don't, so we get
rid of it. And now we click the
help button. Now I'm going to try and
log in with this. It's going to fail.
I hope it's going to fail, but it
should fail because I added as part of
the configuration
that our team has to be tutorial to
get access to the cluster.
So if I do this, this team doesn't
exist yet. We haven't created it.
But you'll see that my Teleport tutorial application
by Rawkode Academy,
I have lots of different organizations, but we'll
skip past that.
And we get unable to process callback.
Is that the error message I'm expecting?
Not sure, but we're gonna find out.
I think that Teleport Rawkode is alive. I'm
gonna double check.
There's config.
Teleport Rawkode. Yeah. I think it's okay.
And I didn't mess that up in here.
Teleport.org. Yeah. I think we're good. I think
that is just a weird error message for
the team problem, but we're gonna fix that
now. So we'll come back to those Rawkode
Academy settings. We'll try no. We don't want
team discussions. We want teams.
Go to my profile,
teams,
new team,
and we'll call this one tutorial
and click create.
Now I'm already a member of this because
I am the owner of the organization.
So let's try.
Hopefully,
again.
Wonderful.
And now we have access to Teleport. So
now we can connect
to
the nodes. Oh, I haven't given myself user
access, but that's okay.
We can modify the GitHub configuration to support
that there.
Wonderful.
So I do see that we have a
question from
Ali.
Hello.
Long one.
First time I look the Teleport and it
seems amazing.
It is.
However, I was wondering what is the difference
between Hashicorp Vault and Teleport? Are there any
pros and cons?
Yeah. That's
a good question. So
Teleport
cannot really be compared to HashiCorp Vault.
Vault is a KMS system. It stores secrets,
encryption keys, and valuable information, which can be
exposed to one or many users or groups
depending on the level of access they have
to the vault based on paths and prefixes.
So you could probably actually use vault along
with
Teleport.
However, you can compare
Teleport to
HashiCorp's boundary.
Now, boundary is far from feature parity with
what we get from Teleport. So really, I'm
just gonna see Teleport is probably lead Teleport
is leading here.
And I would encourage everybody to really go
down this path.
With access to Linux systems, to databases, to
Kubernetes, to applications,
and even desktop, Windows desktop,
for example, which we did a video on
recently
with Ben from that team, from the Teleport
team.
So Teleport, it just went us hands down.
Although there are a similar products out there,
but
we like Teleport. It's great.
All right. Let's
fix
some stuff.
If we come in here,
We don't need to worry about this.
I'm just curious about the spec for the
users.
Computer is being weird.
Alright. Let's just find that.
So one of my favorite pages in the
documentation,
if I can remember where it is.
The architecture.
Let's see. Reference.
Oh, there's more references and then dot.
Reference.
And then we have the config fail.
Does this include
GitHub?
Alright. Let's see.
That's taking me back.
Alright.
Let's take a look at one I already
use.
I forgot I didn't remove all the SSH
keys from the organization,
but that's alright.
We can take a look at the clustered
setup because we already did this here.
So if we come into clustered and take
a look at the
cluster automation and inside this, we have a
whole bunch of cloud edit scripts and a
whole bunch of main setup, Teleport.
And if we take a look at
Nope, not Teleport install.
I don't think it's the agent actually either.
Not yet. Oh, maybe?
No.
Teleport server. There you go. I wrote these
scripts. Okay. So
what we do here is you see logins
Rawkode.
So we're using the access role. So we
could modify that. That's a good point, actually.
Or we could create a new role. Let's
create a new role. Let's do it in
a proper way.
So what I'm gonna do here is copy
this rule template
and we'll just do this. I think we
can get away with just doing this all
in the water.
We use three lanes as a separator, and
I'm gonna have to swap out some stuff
that I normally interpret and manually manually automatically.
And we'll create this rule here. So this
is a very inclusive rule. This is my
super special rule when I am filming clustered.
And we actually did a Teleport Rback deep
dive session, which you can find at Rawkode.live
if you just search for Teleport Rback.
But here, we're saying, okay, we have a
team,
and I'm gonna call this team Rawkode.
And this is the bit that was missing
from just using the straight access rule is
that we have to tell it which logins
we have access to. So by default with
the access role,
it becomes a service. You'll see that when
I click connect, I get my own username.
That just means that that username actually needs
to exist on the host
or the login will fail. And in fact,
I think the error message is user unknown.
So
here, if we just say that actually this
person can
access or communicate using the root user, which
is what we wanna use here. Of course,
there are pros and cons to this. As
far as node labels go, I'm gonna go
with wonderful star star for today.
It should be here. And I'm not fussed
about app labels. We don't have any applications
exposed at the moment.
Okay.
This is my super role, which I don't
think
we are going to need right now. So
we can just remove this. But this is
just very explicit and allowing me to actually
manage the Teleport cluster. This is a modified
editor role.
So there's a lot of permissions here, but
we don't need that for today's session.
Bigger than I remember.
There we go. Really, I should have been
using some VEM key vagrants here. Key
the. Okay.
So now we're gonna get myself the Rawkode
role. So this role should be able see
any machine and log in as rich. Let's
try that again.
Teleport.get
up.
Seems nicer.
Okay.
Let's do a refresh. Now do I need
to log out and then perhaps, so let's
sign out, refresh my credentials.
And now we have access to root and
now we are on our
machine.
Simple.
So
thanks for tuning in. That is our GitHub
authentication web Teleport video.
We got
Ali says, thanks for the explanation. No problem.
That's why I like doing these things live
so we can get some questions and hopefully
make your life a little bit easier.
All right. We've got another big question.
Will it fit in the screen? Yeah, I'll
get there. I also started testing Teleport as
our access management solution. I'm wondering how others
handle joining all scaling group instances when scaling
happens or EKS node groups.
For EKS, you can deploy
remove that off my face. For EKS, you
could deploy Teleport
inside of your Kubernetes cluster using some privileged
access to get anything that you need onto
the host is one way. With the auto
scaling grip, you're gonna wanna use
custom launch configuration,
which may configure Teleport
to
which will mean the machines when they spin
up automatically add the things that you need
for Teleport for that to work.
I'll link to one thing really quickly before
I go off there,
which is machine ID. So this is a
really new feature.
Go.
This is a really new feature with Teleport
nine. We actually did a session on this
with Ben as well.
So there's like that.
Teleport
nine.
Yeah, go to this Q and A
with Ben Adams from the Teleport team. We
actually do a demo and talk about machine
ID in much more detail, but machine ID
will allow you to use cloud, KMS, etcetera,
to kind of broker that initial connection
and a machine configuration also works with CICD.
So it's worth looking at
and playing with an experiment with.
Okay. A question from Russell.
Assume
on the screen, I assume that all the
other features of Teleport are available when using
GitHub authentication,
I e, simply access via approvals.
Yeah. So the OAuth Dance just gets you
mapped to a Teleport role and then all
the other features will function as normal.
So any of those cool features like privilege
elevation,
etcetera,
all just work.
Alright. Well, thanks for your time today. We've
got another three videos left in this Teleport
course coming within the next two weeks. All
juggles around KubeCon,
but I'm excited.
And we'll get you more
because let's face it, right? We've already seen
in the six months that I've been working
on this course that Teleport have shipped three
major versions. So when Teleport ten ships, I'll
be sure to update this course and keep
the content coming. So
if you like these videos, thumb it up,
share it with your friends and colleagues, and
remember to subscribe to the channel. And I'll
see you all soon. Thanks for your time.
Bye.